i was actually scared of my own hands
on some days or i wouldn't go out of the
door
through the thought of i'm not angry
today i might just let somebody that's
not even done anything
[Music]
i'd always be like shouting and bawling
or getting into trouble and
um just not functioning like a
normal person as they call it i had a
complete breakdown and
went through quite a lot of emotional
and personal stuff as well
i literally wake up in the morning and
if i wasn't going to get through that
day then i'd go in on a line of cocaine
so i could
smile and wake up and then by the end of
the day i need a drink so i could then
go to sleep
i was out at christmas and i'd ended up
getting in trouble with the police
i took an on-foot chase handcuffed to
him in a dress
um drunk around half my estate and they
still ended up getting me in the
policeman anyway
and i think um when he did arrest me
eventually i went oh i'll give you
something to arrest me for and just dead
buttered in
i was actually scared of my own hands
on some days or i wouldn't go out of the
door
through the thought of i'm not angry
today i might just let somebody that's
not even done anything
yourself up from this period i spoke to
my gym teacher and and i said um
can can you get me ready my fitness
ready someone can box i need to
learn how to control these hands i don't
want to get in trouble again
um and so um he trained me
um on my fitness levels to get me ready
to go to a boxer signed up for a white
collar boxing
i was on a page for stand-ins for like
when mike called they do white collar
shows and
people drop out last minute so i was on
a page for them so that's how it started
really
so your first that first fight when just
just before you're about is about the
bells where to go and you're about to
fight
how excited were you it was more that
all of this time that
this this game plan i have had in my
head now make it work
i wasn't bothered about the thousand
people there or shouting and thinking my
my head was so in this is my fight and
this is how i'm gonna do it and it was
i was kind of like just didn't feel
anything i felt like completely
um focused on this is what
my game plan i say it was a fair match
because we perfect weight wouldn't
neither of us had ever fought before
but i went in there and wanted it and i
won
and i i earned it in there when them
when they said
me it was like whoa i just looked
straight up to the sky
um i don't know who was thanking up
there at the time but
i had a couple of home shows in that
during that but i used all the journey
jobs to
um just for me to to be out there and
practice what it was i was training and
different
different places i go i was learning
different things in different areas from
the different people
to train the same thing again and again
and again but until you're in that fight
then
you can't use it for a southpaw one time
and then afford tall people and short
people and
heavier people and lighter people and i
kind of like it just
well-rounded with it i never
underestimate anybody because even if
they say this
person's never boxed before in their
life that makes absolutely no difference
because some of the people that really
have never boxed before in the life
do exactly what they're told and bumper
really
i'm always polite i'm always real nice
wherever i go to what area i go to
and afterwards i always you know give
them the hug
and to me it's respect they've welcomed
me into the area and
to me i learned just from being in there
there's no need for
for to be rude one girl did when she
touched gloves
hit me as she was touching gloves and to
me
i was told no by one of my coaches no we
don't do that we touch gloves
but wait a second and then you go so
that really annoyed me but you could
tell in it and i was like
you [ __ ]
probably my bare knuckle one that i'm
most proud of and the more that i
researched that nobody had
done it for a belt more that i couldn't
find anybody to do it the more i wanted
to do it
everybody thought it was absolutely
insane and i thought well actually
you know when i first went to the gym i
couldn't get out of the gym without
having an asthma attack so
i still managed to do that and it was
like and i wasn't meant to be able to
get in the ring when i did that so i
thought well
if someone says i can't do it i'll damn
well show him i can
i don't think he used any anger in that
fight so if i i didn't actually feel
great in the bionicle fight
i didn't feel like i have my firing
missile that day
i had my skills in my head and my head
was working but
my fire wasn't in me that day and
i was just so careful to protect myself
and
we have crap days by round one she'd
killed me off that
or not killed me off my head was a mess
by two i answered will be careful and
i did pick up a bit and by three then
she'd caught me with my eye and he'd
stopped it but since then i've spoke to
that ref again and was like why did you
stop it
and he went your eye and i was like i
would have carried on
and he said i know you'd have carried on
that's why i stopped it
i was gutted afterwards but my face
hanging off and
the reality of stood there was actually
i'm just grateful to be alive and
you know i'm still the other person
opposite her we're still the first
people to
have done it and that's still an
achievement
doing that fight really really showed me
how physically and mentally strong i
really am
as a person that i've got through so
much that
it just taught me i might not won at the
end but i won in life every single day
that i managed to keep getting up and
not making bad choices and i'd give some
bloody good fights
if i'm winning and losing i still give a
good fight
you